ich habe natürlich auch eine Frage an
den Grafen und zwar vor kurzem habe ich
den Song geboren um zu leben ein
bisschen umgeschrieben für die WM wir
schreiben dieses Jahr wieder ein Stück
Geschichte holen uns den vierten Stern
der Sieg ist nicht mehr fern wie findest
du
diese umgetextete Version deines
Meisterwerkes geboren um zu
leben Team
Deutschland ihr geboren um zu siegen mit
den Wundern dieser Zeit also als ich das
gesehen habe habe ich
gelacht ich denke erst h und dann ja
wahnsinn was Fußball soll in den
Menschen alles auslöst ja also ich habe
damit überhaupt kein Problem also viele
Leute haben immer oder viele Künstler
haben immer ein Problem wenn ihre Lieder
irgendwie dann anders irgendwie
interpretiert werden ich find es ja hat
mir auch Spaß gemacht aber die
Originalversion von mir gefällt dann
noch ein bisschen besser aber trotz
allem ja immer immer am Ball bleiben und
versuchen ja kreativ zu sein
super geboren um Zuegen mit den Wundern
dieser Zeit das nie zu vergessen wir hol
zurück was uns gebüt wir W geboren um zu
siegen für den einen Augenblick bei dem
jeder von uns spürte wie wertvoll
Deutschland
ist wie wertvoll fußball
ist wir W geboren um zu
siegen mit dem wundern dieser
Zeit geboren und zu
Siegen geboren und zu siegen mit den
Wunden dieser
Zeit viel nie zu vergessen wir zurück
was uns wir geboren und zu liegen für
den einenugen BCK bei den jeder von un
spürte Wert voll Deutschland ist wir W
geboren um zu siegen mit den Wundern
dieser Zeit dass wir nie zu vergessen
ihr zurück was uns Gemüt ich w geboren
um zu siegen für den einen
Augenblick bei den jeder von uns spürte
wie wertvoll Deutschland
ist wir waren geboren um zu
siegen